you were a bartender and I just love
that you would be such a good bartender
Marco flu Thank You generous don't you
know he'd do a generous pour he would
always be a sport I would do a general
yeah mostly because people would be like
come on man didn't you have your own
cocktail
I had the margarita margarita ended up
having you know I'd start early and I'd
had my my Thursday night crowd yeah
partially because and I'm sorry Sean
Macpherson wherever you are I gave away
a lot of free drinks it wasn't a great
quality in a bartender but you were good
dealing with with drunk customers which
is I had to deal with a lot of drunk
people yes and sometimes they were not
very nice no there would be nights where
I'd be up to my eyeballs in a holes
nothing
what what say nothing
Oh No was there a guy who wanted
[Applause]
walls in there a drunk guy isn't that
kind of bar
guy who wanted a sambuca yes sir okay so
tell us about him so occasionally you
would get someone who was so obnoxious
and it was the end of the night and this
guy came in and he's like and he was
wasted and he was such an a-hole
and he's like I want a sambuca I'm like
come on man you're doing okay give me a
sambuca and did he hit you I'm like okay
so I porins and Bucca like it I'm not
gonna let you drink man
I don't like drinks okay you want to let
your drink you like you drink yourself
light it okay I like the drink he takes
it mm-hmm and it goes all over his face
dripping down his face blue flames
everywhere
and I'm trying not to laugh and he beats
the hell out of himself
get another sure thing
brought me to light it for you
yes same thing it was one of the
greatest nights I sort of like him for
having another world I love them he
walked out with like like a flaming red
goatee
that brings back a really painful memory
it was you
I was like 12 13 I I was lit was a late
bloomer but I had a premature mustache
like I had hair there and nowhere else
right
I mean my head of course and and I was
begging my dad cuz kids were making fun
of me like your stache swimmer your most
you know and so I was begging my dad hey
can I please shave and my dad was like
you're too young to shave I'm sorry but
I was I took matters into my own hand
and I borrowed some of my sister's Nair
for those of you who don't know it's
like a chemical hair removal if we go to
eMac eMac yes okay so I put it on my lip
but I left it on too long so I had a
burn mark just like only it would you
know I had to then go to school I tried
my hair off and they're like what the so
all these other names so I'm sorry to
bring up we live that trauma but share
that
[Applause]
[Music]
you